[Música]
en su paso por Florida como huracán de
categoría 4 y han dejado 2,4 millones de
hogares y negocios sin electricidad Se
esperan fuertes vientos y lluvias
torrenciales en otros estados y el
presidente
alertó que podría ser el más mortífero
en la historia del estado
nuevos ataques rusos con misiles dejaron
varios muertos en las ciudades
ucranianas de nipro y nikolaid entre
tanto Vladimir Putin anunció que mañana
firmará la anexión de los territorios
ucranianos sometidos a referendos de
adhesión y que se subsanarán los errores
de la movilización parcial que fue
criticada hoy por celenski
los brasileños eligen a su nuevo
presidente este domingo 2 de octubre y
en francés 24 les hemos preparado una
serie de reportajes especiales para
contextualizar estos comicios hoy
hablamos de los votos de los jóvenes y
de los evangélicos que son cruciales
para estas elecciones
Bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
Franz 24 y Rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos abrimos esta emisión con la
actualización de Ian ahora degradado a
tormenta tropical pero que azotó Florida
como uno de los huracanes más poderosos
que llega a Estados Unidos en los
últimos años en su camino dejó graves
inundaciones y daños millonarios en
Orlando ya como tormenta tropical y han
dejó a niveles históricos de lluvia lo
que obligó a que los servicios de
emergencia tuvieran que trasladar en
botes a algunos residentes el Centro
Nacional de Huracanes estadounidense aún
mantiene su alerta y se esperan fuertes
vientos lluvias torrenciales y marejadas
ciclónicas en otros estados el
presidente joeyden advirtió sobre la
gravedad de la situación
se podría hacer el huracán más mortífero
en la historia de Florida los números
aún no están claros pero estamos
escuchando los primeros informes de lo
que puede ser una pérdida sustancial de
Vidas
aprové la solicitud más reciente del
gobernador para una declaración
acelerada de desastre mayor esto
significa que el Gobierno Federal
cubrirá el 100% del costo de limpiar los
escombros y todos los costos que el
estado tiene que hacer en los que tiene
que participar y expandirse para salvar
vidas
y noticias relacionadas con la guerra en
Ucrania las autoridades de la región
ucraniana de Nitro petrox denunciaron un
nuevo ataque ruso con misiles estos
habrían alcanzado la ciudad de nipro
dejando cuatro muertos y cinco heridos
en zonas civiles de la urbe en la ciudad
de nikolaive otro misil dejó tres
fallecidos todo ello el mismo día en que
Vladimir Putin confirmó que mañana
firmará los tratados de anexión de los
territorios ucranianos sometidos a
referendos de adhesión que siguen
generando polémica y rechazo en parte de
la comunidad internacional hoy el
secretario general de la ONU Antonio
Gutiérrez volvió a criticarlos
la posición de las Naciones Unidas es
inequívoca estamos totalmente
comprometidos con la soberanía la unidad
la independencia y la integridad
territorial de Ucrania dentro de sus
fronteras internacionalmente reconocidas
de conformidad con las resoluciones
pertinentes de la ONU quiero señalar que
los llamados referéndums en las regiones
ocupadas se llevaron a cabo durante un
conflicto armado activo en áreas bajo
ocupación rusa y fuera del marco legal y
constitucional de Ucrania no pueden
llamarse la expresión genuina de la
voluntad popular cualquier decisión de
Rusia antes de seguir adelante pondrá en
peligro aún más la perspectivas de paz
también este jueves el presidente de
Rusia habla de mil Putin afirmó durante
una reunión del Consejo de Seguridad de
su país que se corregir los errores
cometidos durante la movilización
militar parcial de 300.000 reservistas a
combatir en Ucrania
los errores deben corregirse y no se
pueden cometer en el futuro se trata de
aquellos ciudadanos que califican para
el aplazamiento por ejemplo padres que
tienen muchos hijos o personas que
padecen enfermedades crónicas o aquellos
que no pueden ser reclutados por su
mayoría de edad es necesario investigar
cada caso como este por separado si el
error se ha cometido repito que se debe
corregir y devolver a casa a los que
habían sido reclutados sin razones
precisamente una de las consecuencias de
esta movilización ha sido la huida de
ciudadanos rusos a países limítrofes
sobre este tema se pronunció el
presidente de Ucrania bolodimirselensky
López
durante la primera semana de
movilización criminal ya han huido de
Rusia más hombres de los que las
autoridades rusas planeaban oficialmente
enviar de guerra y cómo reacciona El
Criminal ante Esto está enviando a los
militares a la frontera rusa contra los
mismos ciudadanos de Rusia esto es una
vergüenza y las mentiras con algunos
pseudos referéndums con algunas
confesiones y anexiones terminarán en
una vergüenza aún mayor para Rusia
y la guardia costerada de Suecia detectó
una cuarta fuga de gas en el gasoducto
ruso nord Stream en el mar Báltico tanto
las autoridades alemanas como las suecas
y las danesas mantienen su teoría de que
esto se trata de un Sabotaje cuyo origen
está siendo investigado por su parte la
otan aseguró que responderá unida y con
determinación ataques deliberados contra
infraestructuras críticas de los aliados
además las autoridades medioambientales
alemanas alertan de los daños que las
fugas de metano pueden causar al
ecosistema
comenzó en la haya al juicio contra
félixsienka buga 28 años después de su
papel vital en el genocidio de Ruanda de
1994 el tribunal Busca responsabilizar a
kabuga por su contribución intencional
al genocidio contra 800.000 personas de
la etnia el empresario ruandés de 87
años es acusado de adquisición y
distribución de armas también de crear y
dirigir la radio televisión libre de
milkolín emisora emisora que fomentó el
odio y la violencia contra los tutsi
ante tanto en Ruanda aún perduran las
huellas de la masacre
sobrevivió al genocidio tutsi en 1994
sus dos hermanos fueron asesinados en
este barrio de la capital ruandesa
estaban matando a la gente aquí donde yo
estoy había cadáveres por todas partes y
los tiraban en la cuneta o en una fosa
común los habitantes del barrio de
mujima siguen viviendo a la sombra de
este edificio construido por Félix
siembra acusado por la justicia
internacional de financiar las masacres
en aquella época epafrodita vivía cerca
del edificio escapó de las milicias
futuos que masacraron a los tutsis tras
el genocidio se unió a ibuka una
organización de supervivientes apoyada
por el gobierno
ese edificio de ahí era la casa de feliz
y en kabuga albergaba una base del
Antiguo partido en el poder el mrn D los
milicianos del barrio venían a [__] sus
armas aquí venían del Norte del país
salieron de la casa cuando se les ordenó
ir a matar
tras más de 20 años huida feliz la
tortuga fue detenido en Francia en 2020
un tribunal especializado le acusa
también de financiar radio de milkolín
que alentaba la masacre
había muchos mensajes que decían que los
tutsi son enemigos del país que hay que
matarlos así se convenció a muchos
extremistas de que había que matar
extremistas
por su responsabilidades en los medios
de comunicación extremistas kabuga será
juzgado por incitación a cometer
genocidio Ruanda emitió más de 40
órdenes de detención internacional
contra presuntos genocidas residentes en
Francia Todavía están pendientes según
las autoridades holandesas para las que
el juicio de filicianka buga es un
asunto urgente El tiempo pasa y la gente
envejece los organizadores murieron y no
nos enteramos hasta 10 o 15 años después
y nunca fueron a juicio Eso es malo para
la historia del país y para las víctimas
ya se ha declarado No culpable sus
abogados han pedido que se suspenda el
juicio debido a su mal estado de salud
Vamos hasta Irán donde el presidente
ebrain raíz y condenó el caos tras las
protestas encabezadas por mujeres tras
la muerte de maxa Mini de 22 años la
joven murió mientras estaba bajo la
custodia de la policía de la moral de la
República islámica Los que participaron
en los disturbios deben ser tratados con
firmeza dijo el presidente
ultraconservador acusando a Estados
Unidos de avivar los disturbios más en
el siguiente informe
filmado discretamente desde un vehículo
la policía antidisturbios armada y con
ropa protectora se despliega en las
calles de jacks en el centro de Irán
aquí no se toleran las manifestaciones
pero desde el 16 de septiembre las
mujeres son las protagonistas de
protestas antigubernamentales en las que
denuncian no solo la muerte de marza
amini sino también la estructura
conservadora de Irán esto cuando el
presidente ultraconservador del país
condenó las manifestaciones el miércoles
la seguridad de las personas es la línea
Roja de la República islámica de Irán y
nadie puede violar la ley y provocar el
caos
Irán llevó a cabo el miércoles
mortíferos ataques transfronterizos en
el norte de Irak dirigidos a las sedes
de tres partidos de la oposición kurda
iraní que apoyan las manifestaciones en
curso dentro de Irán como saben las
protestas que se iniciaron en Irán
proceden del kurdistán fue en el
kurdistán donde cobraron impulso y se
extendieron por todo Irán y por eso
consideran que nosotros y los partidos
kurdos estamos detrás de estas protestas
el partido democrático kurdo de Irán
confirmó la muerte de dos de sus
miembros y se informó de que decenas de
personas habían muerto o resultado
heridas en los ataques según el
Ministerio de sanidad de la región del
kurdistán Washington condena los ataques
calificando los de ataque descarado a la
soberanía de Irak y en Francia varios
sectores de trabajadores salieron a las
calles para pedir mejoras en su
situación laboral en forma de aumentos
salarial y buenas condiciones para
pensionarse todo en medio de un
descontento generalizado por el aumento
del costo de la vida y la pérdida de
poder adquisitivo Alba Santana nos
amplía
aumentos salarial mínimo sociales con
reivindicaciones como esta los
trabajadores de Francia salieron a las
calles para pedir dos cosas en concreto
una subida salarial y mejores
condiciones en las pensiones
cuando los precios salarios bajos
disminuyen aún más y los problemas de
poder adquisitivo se agudizan llegar a
fin de meses cada vez más difícil para
más familias en Francia Esto es lo que
hay que solucionar los paros han sido
convocados por algunos sindicatos
franceses tras meses de huelgas en
sectores como el transporte y la
educación y el de la energía que está en
huelga en paralelo a las marchas algo
que ha preocupado al gobierno tras el
recorte la producción de energía nuclear
en medio de la crisis de abastecimiento
en toda Europa
queremos que la energía la electricidad
y el gas Dejen de estar en manos de los
accionistas Porque queremos que es una
necesidad básica para que cualquier
ciudadano pueda calentar su casa y
utilizar la electricidad a un precio
razonable
ahora en medio del aumento de la
inflación y del costo de vida el
gobierno de macon pretende aumentar la
edad legal para jubilarse una medida que
enfrenta una gran oposición y que
incrementaría el malestar social no
obstante el presidente ya insinuado la
posibilidad de convocar elecciones
anticipadas si su reforma de pensiones
no sale adelante y este domingo
precisamente Brasil tiene elecciones
para elegir presidente renueva también
un tercio del senado la totalidad de la
cámara de representantes y elige varios
gobernadores por eso en francés 24 hemos
preparado una serie de reportajes
especiales para aportarles contexto hoy
hablamos del voto de los evangélicos y
de los jóvenes que pueden ser decisivos
el informe es de nuestros corresponsales
en Río de Janeiro
en Brasil el 31% de la población se
declara evangélica cerca de 70 millones
de personas la mitad apoya el presidente
bolsonaro el candidato de la izquierda
necesita conquistar a este colectivo
para ganar es el objetivo de este acto
electoral en Río de Janeiro nunca
hubo en la historia de Brasil un
presidente que trató la religión y las
iglesias con la democracia con la que yo
cuide este país
Jacqueline es profesora y evangélica en
2018 voto a bolsonaro pero este año va a
dar su preferencia a
lulando
a ver mejoras en el área de Educación va
a ayudar a los pobres principalmente en
la periferia de Río de Janeiro donde yo
vivo yo volver a generar empleos
una campaña de noticias falsas acusó a
Lula de querer encerrar las iglesias
evangélicas en caso de Victoria este
candidato lucha por demostrar lo
contrario sabe que el 54% de las mujeres
rechazan a bolsonaro el voto de las
evangélicas es crucial el voto joven es
otro factor clave en estas elecciones
más de un millón de jóvenes de 16 a 18
años como ryanny acudirán por primera
vez a las urnas
cuando me enteré que podía sacar mi
título electoral le dije a mi padre que
quería hacerlo Aunque yo represente solo
el 1% de la población es muy importante
en Brasil antes de los 18 años el voto
no es obligatorio a una sierra y Ani no
quiso perder la oportunidad de escoger a
bolsonaro
ella tiene su propia opinión política yo
no la influencer ella es de derecha
Hace cuatro años
42 millones de brasileños se obtuvieron
votaron nulo o en blanco para esta
politóloga la corrupción fue la razón
principal
la alta competitividad de este pleito
está haciendo que las personas envuelvan
directamente con las dos candidaturas un
fenómeno que no se ve desde hace mucho
tiempo entonces creo que el fenómeno de
la abstensión va a caer este año
esta analista cree que una mayor
participación política puede beneficiar
a la izquierda
informativo sigan conectados
[Música]